watch this video to master
frontrow myokomi
hi guys i'm mihai dobroka from yokohama
aikidojo
in this video i'm gonna show you step by
step how to do
the front roll myocamy it's very
important to practice it correctly and
safely
otherwise you may get injured as a first
step
i recommend you to start on the ground
so one knee up one knee down and
i'm gonna roll over my shoulder i i'm
not gonna roll over my head like a
somersault
we want to avoid any risk of injury of
the head
and the spine so also the shape of the
hand is important
for example if you bend your elbow
like this you may hit it or if you put
your arm like this
during the ukami you may injure your
shoulder
we don't want to do that so make sure
that you shape a strong
circle with your arms and
the fingers pointing backwards put your
pinky
on the ground and you may take your
balance
using your other hand and i'm gonna roll
on this straight line
in the order of my wrist elbow shoulder
on the opposite hip and knee so from
here this position
i'm gonna lift my hips a little bit
shift my weight
forward and
roll like this
on the other side circle
take balance raise the hips and
try first try to roll as slow
as it's possible
okay in on a straight line beginners
sometimes do it like this
rolling on this right on the side that's
really not want
uh it's really not that what you want to
get
so make sure that all your movement is
on a line
and you roll nicely and safely
next from standing i'm gonna start from
a wide humming position
i'm gonna drop down my center and bend
both of my knees
the hand position is same just like
before and i'm gonna roll
uh slowly as low as it is possible on
this straight line
and from here stand up and hand me
so start from humming position drop down
your center
make a circle also try to watch your
belly
so you can keep your back circular
and humming as you get confidence
you can increase the speed and also go
more to the front
in actual practice when we get from
the partner is standing behind us so we
have to turn backwards
a very simple or common way to do this
is
just to turn like this
using a tank i step or in other way
what i personally prefer to do is to get
in a toe crunch position
turning as fast as it is possible and
then i can use both of my legs to stand
up straightly
and humming position
another way that you can see in the
aikikai circle
is something like this
however uh during this motion you're
gonna expose your back towards your
partner for a long time
and this way is definitely slower or
an other way is something like this
it's a judo type ukami which is uh i
guess common in yoshinka and atomic
style
in the case when i have to do a roll
outside on a hard surface like concrete
or a spot
i definitely want to protect my knees
and i don't want to put them
on the hard surface so i would exit the
ukami something like this
here is an extra exercise i like to do
to develop
good body coordination and control
in this exercise my partner is going to
push me from backwards
i don't want to get stiffed or freeze i
try to
stay relaxed and absorb his power and
execute the front row
you can use the other leg
it doesn't matter he can also push me to
the side
so for example
like this or
next exercise we are going to start from
a handshake position
like this he's going to turn front of me
and kneel down
and he can put my hand front of my leg
or far like that it doesn't matter
the important thing that i have to
adjust my movement and execute a safe
front row
once more
and now the application category
as he moves i try to feel what's going
on stay in contact
uh he's gonna throw me and
i'm gonna step in and use my free hand
to execute a safe front row
now on the other side and
just move together okay next which
kaiten koken again
or another application
thank you for watching if you like this
video please consider subscribing to my
channel
see you in the next video
you